this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer money climate
stabilization plans depend upon the
power sector moving towards net zero
carbon dioxide output by 2050 to achieve
this fossil fuel power plants are
beginning to close around the world coal
the world's stable energy source for
centuries has steadily fallen out of
favour since 2015 with a 70% drop in new
construction projects this decline
cannot be entirely pinned on shifting
global attitudes to climate change
economic pressures have been the driving
force for many of the closures as solar
and wind energy continues to get cheaper
California is among the most proactive
places in the world when it comes to
renewable energy and they have a good
reason to be droughts and wildfires have
plagued the state in recent years and
trends indicate that they will continue
to get worse with increasing global
temperature over the past eight years
Californian energy sources have shifted
dramatically in 2010 their energy
sources looked like this with the
majority of energy coming from natural
gas hydroelectricity nuclear and
geothermal in 2018 each of these energy
sources has dropped in the percentage of
total energy production with solar
rising to an astounding 19% in just
eight years and wind more than doubling
to 6.5 percent last year Californian
lawmakers set a goal of reaching 100%
renewable energy for the states by 2045
and at this rate California are on track
but California's progress is about to
get a lot more expensive and difficult a
switching to 100% renewable energy even
in sunny California is not quite as easy
as installing solar panels
let's discover why by visiting Moss
Landing in beautiful Monterey Bay this
natural gas power plant began producing
energy in 1950 with the nameplate power
capacity of six hundred and thirteen
megawatts by 2002 it was the largest
power plant in the state of California
with the power capacity of two thousand
five hundred and sixty megawatts it has
gone through many changes in those
seventy years of operation
with older less efficient systems been
retired and replaced with modern more
efficient and cleaner systems last year
the latest update for the facility was
announced with an unprecedented battery
storage facility totalling 567 megawatts
of storage making it the largest battery
installation in the world this battery
storage facility is designed to take
over the Moss Landing power plants role
as a peeker station providing surges of
energy to the grid when needed and thus
decreased California's use of natural
gas
California's grid operator provides life
and historical stats on power generation
and consumption let's take a look at a
typical day in the state this is the
energy supply for May 24th 2018 this
line is the power gained from
hydroelectricity
we can see a steady base load is
provided by nuclear energy from the
Diablo Canyon power plant which is this
flat output line this supply deviates
very little throughout the year
providing a steady two thousand two
hundred and eighty megawatts about 90
percent of the needs of the state this
power station rarely varies its load
because it takes a tremendous amount of
time to do so here we can see the very
noticeable spike of renewable energy
starting at 6 a.m. as the Sun rises on
this day thirty four point five percent
of California's electricity was provided
by renewable energy
51% of that being from solar this is
fantastic but we have one big problem
solar energy began to drop off at 5 p.m.
just as California's population was
about to leave work and get stuck in
traffic for hours before arriving home
to turn on their air-conditioning cook
their dinners and watch TV this results
in a peak power demand at eight thirty
four and a half hours after our solar
supply peaked in order to deal with this
demand California begins to ramp up its
natural gas power stations which can
quickly raise their energy output to
deal with surges in demand California
also imported a significant amount of
energy from other states primarily wind
and hydro electricity from the Pacific
Northwest a nuclear coal a natural gas
from Nevada as California looks towards
a carbon neutral energy supply they're
looking to remove these natural gas
power state
and replaced them with batteries that
can store excess solar electricity so it
is available when needed this battery
installation in Moss Landing is going to
fill that role and make no mistake
batteries are now cheap enough to be a
financially viable solution for
California at small scales like this
allowing power companies to buy cheap
solar energy and sell it on for a profit
when demand requires however this
business model does not last very long
as we scale up let's calculate how much
battery storage California would need to
replace just this natural gas peaking
power on May 24th 2018 step 1
Don load the data from this day and
graft the natural gas power output this
data has a resolution of five minutes
but we are going to reduce a resolution
to an hour to make the data easier to
Paris we will assume our new grid will
contain a steady base load of natural
gas power at four thousand two hundred
and twenty megawatts which is a 10% drop
in our natural gas use for the day and a
1.7 percent drop when expressed as a
percentage of total energy use on the
day in an ideal world I think California
would be generating this base load using
nuclear energy but that seems unlikely
as early last year
regulators voted to close the Diablo
Canyon power plant California's last
nuclear power plant we can now clearly
see the energy we need to provide with
batteries as this area that rises above
our base load to calculate it we simply
need to calculate the area of this
section which will give us our battery
storage requirements in megawatt hours
this comes out to be about eleven
thousand two hundred megawatt hours of
energy storage Tesla's one hundred and
twenty-nine megawatt hour battery
storage facility for horns Dale firm in
Australia came with a price tag of
fifty-six million dollars extrapolating
that figure out to an eleven thousand
two hundred megawatt hour battery we
could expect a total cost of four point
eight six billion dollars we would
likely be able to achieve a lower
battery cost over time as battery prices
continue to lower over time it's not an
absurd number Diablo Canyon power plant
which has about five times the daily
energy output cost 13.8
to construct however it's important to
remember that batteries do not generate
their own energy and in order to make
this a worthwhile endeavor renewable
energy would need to generate a surplus
of electricity during the day to charge
them which California is already doing
everyday California curtails significant
amounts of renewable energy which is not
needed this figure is continually rising
with April 2019 having a record 190,000
megawatt hours wasted on May 7th of this
month an astounding 8000 369 megawatt
hours was curtailed nearly enough to
fully charge our massive battery it's
this cheap energy our Moss Landing
battery farm will be looking to purchase
and sell for a profit however going
forward to May 15th
just 193 megawatt hours was curtailed
even in summer our renewable resources
are highly variable and unreliable this
leaves us vulnerable if we do not have
alternative energy sources like natural
gas or nuclear to pick up the slack but
let's move forward assuming we are going
to rely on solar as Californian
politicians seem to be aiming for this
requires billions of dollars to be spent
building redundant power which can pick
up the slack when needed this problem
becomes particularly apparent in January
in December where our energy generation
falls off a cliff even in sunny
California let's analyze the towpath
solar farm to see the scale of our
problem in order for solar energy to
reliably provide power we need to size
it to give us the necessary power even
in winter months once again we've all
the data we need to figure this out here
is the average energy output for a
single day of each month over the past
four years of this farms operation as we
can see our energy generation drops from
a peak of four thousand three hundred
and eighty eight megawatt hours in June
to a low of two thousand six hundred and
thirty seven megawatt hours in January
this differential is actually quite good
and other solar farms can see a larger
drop in production but for now we will
be generous so to charge our eleven
thousand two hundred megawatt hour
battery using this
power source in winter we would need a
solar farm 4.25 times bigger than topaz
firm this solar farm costs 2.4 billion
to construct so once again scaling
linearly we could expect a cost of 10.2
billion for solar farm of this size now
this presents a new problem at our peak
power in summer we are generating on
average an excess of seven thousand four
hundred and thirty seven megawatt hours
a day if this energy cannot find a home
grid operators have to shut it down to
prevent it from overloading the grid to
prevent the energy being curtailed it
can be exported assuming neighboring
states are also not over producing or we
can add more storage to the grid which
would cost roughly 3.2 billion using the
same method of estimation from earlier
you can see a pattern emerging here to
increase solar we need to add more
batteries in order to add more batteries
we need to add more solar and it
eventually gets to a point where
batteries dominate costs caused explode
as we increase our reliance on renewable
energy and storage here to just increase
our renewable resources by 1.9 to maybe
2.5% we have reached a total estimated
cost of eighteen point two six billion
dollars four point six billion more than
the construction cost of Diablo Canyon
nuclear power station while producing
less power these costs bloat more and
more as we increase our reliance on
renewables in order to ensure we have
enough power in the winter months we
have to build excessive amounts of
renewable energy sources or we can try
to store the excess power from the
summer months and save it for a rainy
day
at which point our costs become
dominated by batteries the clean air
task force an MIT research group
estimated that California would require
nine point six million megawatt hours of
energy storage at 80 percent renewable
usage and thirty-six point three million
megawatt hours of energy storage at 100%
this is equivalent to twelve days and
forty five days worth of energy storage
respectively their rationale for this
which is not clearly given in any of
their documentation but I managed to
track down the original researcher is
this is the storage required to store
all the excess energy in the summer
months when we scale our renewables to
be fifty percent from solar and fifty
percent from wind while not scaling
their power generation to provide enough
energy even on the average winter day a
very strange approach considering
lithium-ion batteries are not suitable
for long-term storage gradually losing
their church this coupled with the costs
associated with batteries along with the
rapidly falling price of solar and wind
energy makes me very skeptical of the
number thirty six point three million
megawatt hours of energy storage if we
gave a generous future adjusted price of
one hundred dollars per kilowatt hour
would come out at a price of three point
six three trillion dollars more than the
three trillion gross domestic product of
California for 2018 this for me is an
over simplistic approach so let's set
forth our own plan taking January of
this year as an example we are going to
scale our power for this month as it's
our worst case scenario downloading the
data for every single day of the month
we can see the energy demand per day
varying like so now if we place our
solar generation on the same graph we
can see it generated an average of 8.2
percent of our total generation with a
low of 2.1 percent on January fourth and
a high of twelve point seven percent on
January 27th we had consecutive bad days
on the 14th 15th 16th and 17th with only
two point one to point two five point
two and three percent from solar if we
scale this to provide 100 percent of our
energy needs even on our worst day we
can see that the high variation would
add additional costs either in battery
storage or excess solar thankfully if we
now overlay our wind generation we can
see that on those days wind generation
was higher than normal and picked up the
slack a little these were obviously
cloudy stormy days in California this
raises an important point on California
strategy they have been rushing to
install megawatts of solar in recent
years and have not been installing
enough wind wind maybe an overall more
expensive power source for California
but going forward
it's going to be a vital part of
diversifying their power sources if we
add our other renewable power sources
which are geothermal biofuels and small
hydro facilities our new renewables
count comes out like this accounting for
an average of 20 percent of our energy
needs large hydro facilities are
technically a renewable energy source
but are not counted in our total as they
require environmentally destructive dams
they are also not counted as they are
some of the oldest power stations and
policy makers do not want large hydro
facilities watering down their efforts
in increasing other renewable sources
for our purposes this is silly so let's
add it in once again we have smooth it
our output allowing us to be less
reliant on batteries and excess power
closing nuclear stations is also a
questionable move and overall going to
add to our grids costs and
inefficiencies the higher the
probability of dips in renewables on
consecutive days like this the more
batteries we are going to need to store
excess power on other days that also
means we have to install additional
excess power sources in order to ensure
we have excess power to charge our
batteries this can be done in summer
months but as we said batteries are not
well-suited to long-term storage
thankfully many companies are working on
developing cheaper energy solutions for
the grid which will allow us to
cost-effectively store energy currently
the true Holy Grail is developing cheap
storage that will be able to store all
that excess power in the summer months
and allow us to spread it out throughout
the year arpa-e an energy research group
modeled after DARPA the loonatics that
funded this monstrosity invested 30
million dollars in 10 startups trying to
develop this technology some focus on
thermal batteries others thermochemical
and form energy who's developing a
sulfur-based battery received the
largest share of that 30 million these
are technologies that could facilitate a
smaller more efficient renewable grid
and we all cover them in a future
episode so to recap California is
heading towards over reliance on solar
energy it needs to begin diversifying
its renewable portfolio with wind and
other sources continue to slowly build
out these
lithium-ion battery facilities to
replace natural gas peaking power but
unless something dramatically changes
they aren't going to be a panacea to our
renewable energy woes so continued
research into low-cost long-term energy
storage will be vital arpa-e needs to be
supported in this effort this is just a
brief look at California
but while the parameters of this problem
change with different climates and
economies the overall problem is the
same we need every country to be
intelligently optimizing their grid to
accommodate renewables to ensure an
optimized grid is going to require
careful analysis of historical data like
we did above while calculating
statistical likelihood of not fulfilling
demand with different energy systems as
much as I would love to performing a
complete study of this nature is outside
the scope of a YouTube video but if I
was going to do it I would need to brush
up on my Python coding knowledge to
automate the process and my
understanding of statistics both of
which I could do on brilliant taking
these two courses will give you all the
skills you need to take large data sets
like this and make sense of them Python
is one of the most widely used
programming languages and it is an
excellent first language for new
programmers this course will show you
how to use Python to create intricate
drawings coded messages and beautiful
data plots while teaching you some
essential core programming concepts
combine this with the statistics course
to learn more about medians variance and
standard deviation and you'll have all
the skills to make sense of the
mountains of data available on grid
provider sites like this brilliant
recently introduced a new feature called
daily challenges which will present you
with interesting scientific and
mathematical problems to test your brain
every day if I've inspired you and you
want to educate yourself then go to
brilliant org ford slash real
engineering and sign up for free and the
first 500 people to go to that link will
get 20% off the annual premium
subscription so you can get full access
to all their courses as well as the
entire daily challenges archive as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the link
to my Instagram Twitter subreddit and
discord server are below